good morning everybody oh wait wait wait
a second wait a second it's norway time
so good afternoon to you how are you
how does it feel to be back at uh ndc
oslo in person live well sort of live
i'm not there but that's okay
how's it feel feels pretty good right
yeah
i see the guy in the orange jacket in
the front thank you for the thumbs up my
man
appreciate you my name is spencer and i
am here to talk to you today about um
immutable data structures uh in c sharp
and net so um we're going to talk a
little bit a little history we're going
to talk a lot about a little uh
you know platform is it good for is is
immutability good for net is it how does
it how does it fit into the dot-net
world especially c-sharp and nvb.net if
you're a vb.net developer uh well now
out of curiosity since i said it uh
raise your hand if you're uh still
working vb.net on a day-to-day basis
okay raise your hand if you just don't
want to admit it
all right well
i'm really excited to be giving this
talk to you wish i could be there live
in person but uh you know that's the way
it goes sometimes so um thank you for
coming and uh i hope you take away
something from this talk i do have
slido up on my phone so i will be
waiting for questions um i might save
questions for the end um but if somebody
asks a question in the middle that i
think is uh that i think is good then i
will certainly address it so uh without
further ado
i'm ready to get started uh let's talk
about
uh what immutable immutability is or
what immutable means so immutable is an
adjective that means it's unchanging
over time or unable to be changed
and a large part of our world in general
not the programming world just our world
in general lots of things are mutable um
my uh feelings about certain things are
mutable
um my uh day-to-day is mutable um
but immutability some things really some
things do never change and immutability
um is really the concept that describes
that
and
going piggybacking off of that an
immutable object is a data structure
that once instantiated cannot be changed
so
um we've probably heard you know about
immutability at least
in in many walks of life uh sorry in in
many walks of life and in many walks of
our programming life but uh none so uh
very diff not none so more than when we
get to talking about functional
programming now functional programming
is uh when i encountered functional
programming um early on in my career it
was a uh it was for it was f sharp uh i
had just f sharp was fairly new at the
time and i was a fairly new.net
developer
and uh
what really surprised me or really took
me aback about uh f-sharp was how
different even though it was a dot-net
you know ecosystem language how
different functional programming an
f-sharp really was
um compared to something like c-sharp or
vb.net uh
and more less about like the syntax and
more about what f sharp encouraged you
to do and and and its values in general
whereas you know functional programming
really embraces the concept of no null
you know as much as is possible f sharp
can't avoid it because it's a clr
language after all
uh immutability as a default sort of um
as a default
uh way of expressing data structures
uh functions first thus of course the
functional the name functional uh where
functions are really first-class
citizens and are treated as objects uh
in in most cases and
a really nice expressive type system
um which uh thankfully a large part of
that has indeed come over to uh a good
amount of that not not all of it but a
good amount of that has come over to c
sharp um in in in certain things like uh
pattern matching uh which isn't really a
type system thing but a really nice type
system will make fun
things like pattern matching a lot
easier but of course we're not here to
talk necessarily about functional
programming we're here to talk about
immutability specifically um
let's take a little f sharp for example
uh this is how you declare a type inside
of f sharp or at least the most uh basic
way to declare a type and it's called a
record type and um this thing has been
around for years and years inside of
f-sharp uh and it has a couple of uh
features about it that are uh different
by default this type is not mutable in
other words you cannot change these
properties unless you put a little
mutable keyword in front of it um and
this was really one of the first most
surprising things about f-sharp for me
was this sort of concept of a record
where uh it had structural equality by
default it uh is
immute immutable by default uh and that
was really kind of a changing moment for
me
and uh as per usual in c sharp uh it it
borrows all of its best ideas like async
await uh link it borrows all those best
things from uh other languages and of
course now of course we have that in
c-sharp as well uh and it works pretty
much the same at least as you declare it
it is immutable by default although you
can make it mutable uh and
it has structural equality built in
which i think is one of its uh best
aspects so um if you're using a more
recent version of c sharp i don't always
get that privilege because i work a lot
in legacy.net applications so usually i
just stick with what i have um but if
you are working in a more recent version
of c sharp this is certainly an option
for you as well
and it really gets back to what that
idea that functional programming really
changed things it really changed some of
my behaviors in c sharp even though in c
sharp and vb.net
lots of functional things are not you
know a lot lots of functional concepts
are not possible uh you can kinda sorta
uh do function for you can you can do
sort of function first stuff inside of c
sharp uh but it's really not that simple
or straightforward and of course
immutability is there as well
and we'll talk about what that looks
like in a little bit
but of course it's important to know
that you've probably heard this all from
uh
that you've probably heard this all in
some form or another uh from somebody
before because if you've ever met
somebody who's a functional programmer
you'll know because if there it's
anything like working out or doing
crossfit they'll make sure you know
they'll tell you they'll they won't stop
talking about it
so c sharp c sharp is a great and
amazing language uh i have built an
entire career on building c applications
written in c sharp
um
and there's a lot about it to love but
and at the end of the day c sharp is c
sharp and i can't change that uh it is
immutable it's sort of mutable right i
mean they change c sharp all the time
but there are some things about c sharp
that i am just unable to change uh the
fact that it's buttoned to the clr and
the clr highly values um and encourages
mutability in many of its libraries its
frameworks it sort of is what it is
right
i can only take and borrow those
concepts uh from other languages from
other paradigms and really sort of use
them in c sharp uh link is a great
example of something that um
that uh
you know uh collection operators uh that
was added to c sharp later and a hugely
great thing um but for the most part c
sharp has and all and always will for
arguably
will be a mutable language first
so
i can't change c sharp but hopefully
i can change your mind
and i have to warn you now that there's
a lot of bad immutability jokes in this
talk uh which i tell a lot of bad jokes
so some things truly are immutable some
things really do never
change this is a uh a tweet that i
particularly like to call out in this um
in this uh in this talk because i think
it really illustrates a lot of
why i think immutability is really
important and really powerful uh as
we're programming so this is a common
complaint by scott hanselman
twitter give me an edit button you and
autoblue complete both suck um
i've always kind of wondered why an edit
button on twitter made any sense at all
and i i i have to say that i of many
things that i i disagree with people on
twitter about this is probably the idea
of having an edit butter on twitter uh
really doesn't appeal to me so let's
talk about why that is
let's take this tweet a little more
innocuous right defeating traffic is the
ultimate boss battle by elon musk um
okay you know that's kind of funny it's
kind of quirky and you like it uh you
are an avid twitter user of course you
love c-sharp twitter who doesn't love
twitter
right um so you look at this and you're
like okay that's kind of funny i don't
always agree with elon but you know what
i'm going to go ahead and give that a
retweet i'm going to go ahead and click
that rt button and i'm going to post it
to my feed and let everybody else know
uh what what i feel that i feel like
this is a funny tweet for whatever
reason um and then elon let's say for
the sake of argument that there is an
edit button let's say that edit button
on twitter exists and suddenly elon
decides a few minutes later you know
this tweet you know this really isn't
really what i meant to say i meant to
say something more like this where you
know what i just want to see i i want to
uh people who retweet this to say i
agree with what donald trump says 100 of
the time
and this kind of gets into a concept of
understanding the state of your
application as it's running and i love
this quote by john carmack a large
fraction of the flaws in software
development are due to programmers not
fully understanding all the possible
states their code may execute in
let's take that going back and taking
diving deeper into this example with
this edit button what if it's been
retrieved we retweeted suddenly now as
twitter let's say that you're the
engineer at twitter who you know makes
the call for how editing how do we make
editing tweets work within twitter now
you have to ask yourself
so many ques many questions about that
particular tweet in general what if that
tweet that edited tweet has been
retweeted
right what if it's been liked do you
like the old tweet or do you like the
new tweet what if somebody quote
retweeted it and uh you know added some
color or context to that do you use the
old copy of the tweet or do you use the
new copy of the tweet what if somebody's
viewing the tweet hit the retweet button
and as they hit the retweet button just
a split second before that person had
edited that tweet
and do we do things like reset the date
and time stamp
diving even further into this
you're that engineer at twitter you're
the one who's making the call how do we
make this how do we make this work
how does this complicate twitter's
architecture i don't know twitter's
architecture although i think they they
talk about it
but i assume that making a tweet
editable probably makes that pretty
difficult for twitter right not only are
they having to store that one copy of
the tweet do they have to store multiple
copies of the tweet if it's already been
liked and retweeted how do you treat
that do we push those notifications up
to edits for that for up to users for
when that tweet is edited
suddenly you you have to you find
yourself asking many questions just to
see
how just to get to the point of being
able to edit a tweet
whereas if you turn around and you just
don't add that edit button you don't
have to think about that
you don't have to think about
why what what do we do if we do enable
an edit button on twitter right you
don't it's if that tweet is immutable
you have a lot of power because you get
simplicity and simplicity is a really
powerful concept right simplifying your
architecture is something that um all of
us want to do unless you're one of those
programmers who's getting uh paid by the
hour and you know you don't have a
conscience so you just continue to make
things more complicated to keep yourself
with the job i don't think any of us are
like that
but
thus illustrating the point that
immutability is simplicity it's bliss in
its way
in its own way
let's talk about this example this is
something i see all the time uh from
especially junior developers where they
take in a list of objects and it does
something it doesn't matter you know
what it is necessarily but they've
specifically chosen that you take in a
list of objects for this method so
suddenly i'm looking at that maybe
overthinking it maybe not depending on
depends on who wrote it and i think to
myself well why is this a list and not
just a read-only collection or an i
innumerable something along those lines
should i be adding to this list should i
be removing from this list is that
something that somebody wants me to do
if let's say that this isn't a method i
wrote i'm the caller of this method i
know that it's doing the thing that i
want to do should i expect on the other
side of that that it's going to mutate
or change my list in some meaningful way
is that an expectation i should have
why do i have this list instead of
something that i don't have to that that
doesn't mutate it suddenly i'm starting
to think about all these states of this
particular method again
it's it's it's me in a way programming
defensively right i don't know
why that person intended for this thing
to be a to take in a list so suddenly
i'm left thinking and thinking more
about this eventually usually i just get
to the point of like okay i'm just gonna
dig into this method and see do does it
mutate this list and if so should i
expect that uh especially since uh you
notice that there's no xml comments
right because nobody writes xml comments
that's probably not true i write them
when i think they're useful but many
times developers just don't and
you know that is what it is
so
having to dig into that code having to
dig into that method just becomes a
necessity
uh the talk that inspired this talk is a
talk called uh refactoring to
immutability it was given at ndc
probably given more places so if you
have an opportunity to watch it uh i
suggest you do it's got
made by it's written by a guy named
kevin kevin
henny uh it's on youtube and um
he talks about this sort of
synchronization quadrant where up at the
top right corner uh if you well let's
start at the bottom left the sort of
quote unquote ideal or really just the
bottom half where if you have data
that's shared between threads or not
shared between threads or systems as it
were
if you if it's immutable it needs no
synchronization right if that data if
nothing about that data can change
directly like a sql server row right sql
server row they want to be updated
that's just the way sql server rows work
that's how we tend to write applications
is to just mutate them in place so if
you don't have a mutable data a mutable
data structure if it's immutable then
you have no need to synchronize across
threads synchronize across systems in as
much as if edits are made you don't have
to worry about those things
now if you have something let's take the
top left quadrant if you have mutable
data that is not shared you have no
synchronization no need for any
synchronization proce process in order
to make sure that that data is up to
date with other threads with other
systems
um
whereas if you have
pop right shared mutable data suddenly
that data can be changed so now if it's
being changed across memory spaces if
it's being changed across threads you
have to have some kind of
synchronization process in place
and that can get really complicated as
you're getting into things like
multi-threaded programming um
moore's law is really worth take uh is
really worth talking about here because
we are reaching a limit of well we've
pretty much hit that limit of
the single threaded performance well not
necessarily the single threaded
performance but
silicon can only get
we can only make silicon so fast before
we have to just sort of um make it
before we have to sort of start thinking
about spreading the work across multiple
cores across multiple processors
and this started what was you know i
don't remember uh this one was an 09
chip
uh i i don't i don't exactly remember
the timeline but i i started getting
into computers around the time that
pentium 4 was the big thing pentium 4
and um i believe uh there it was athlon
amd's athlon chip and it started what
was known as the gigabit the gigahertz
wars where the chip manufacturers in a
race for uh to reach the limits to get
to the limits the upper limits of
uh you know of single threaded
performance they just started making
their chips their single core chips
faster and faster and faster as fast as
they possibly could
that guy that guy kind of looks familiar
oh
anyways but moore's law has its limits
we can only make chips so fast in a
single a single court ship so fast we
cannot make it much faster
and it doesn't really serve us to make
it much faster as well when we have this
idea of multi-threaded uh computing or
you know as it were spreading the um
spreading the work amongst uh multiple
cloud computers or whatnot or
so we have to really think about
really think about when we're sharing
this data between states is it really
worth it to make it mutable if we're
making if we're spreading this work out
or is it much easier to make it
immutable when we're spreading this work
abroad across multiple memory spaces and
this is really important today more than
ever because
we're not getting the single core chips
much faster and we're not going to get
the we're reaching limits there
multi-threaded is the is is the is our
current world and will continue to be
for the foreseeable future for pretty
much ever until they have quantum
computing or whatever that is i don't i
have no idea
so
talking about some history of
immutability i think we've all had this
rite of passages.net developers where uh
we
declared a string as a junior developer
and then we said hey i'm gonna i'm gonna
call this string.replace and i just want
to replace this question mark with an
exclamation point and we were baffled to
find out why is it still printing
replaceable question mark when i
replaced that aspect of that string well
immutability has been around c sharp
forever
in strings
right and that's a really good thing
that's a really powerful idea right
because
there's there at least there was no good
reason necessarily to make strings
mutable from the get-go so we've all had
this right of passage of course all of
us look at this code today it's like of
course we know what this does this is
also super obvious to us
but it wasn't so obvious to me as a
junior developer because immutability i
didn't really understand immutability uh
but once i started reading about strings
i you know that that came right up same
thing goes for something like date time
now uh another another thing that we've
all probably encountered these are this
is an immutable data structure by
default which is a good thing uh and
we've all had this similar thing happen
but c sharp has really had a really
storied history when it comes to
immutability this
was immutability uh when it was first
you know when when when you first had c
sharp
uh this is what you had to do you had to
declare a back and field you had to
declare a string with or a property with
just a getter uh or you could just
declare it without the property you
didn't have to have the property there
but you know we c-sharp likes you to
wrap properties so that's what we did
and this is how you would declare an
immutable struct or an immutable class i
mean um this works this did the job but
it was also very ugly
uh it wasn't you know good looking code
but then we get to you know another
version of c sharp you know a couple
years later
okay now we got the next version of c
sharp and now you have private setters
uh which makes the code just a little
bit cleaner but still technically
mutable of course you know the thing can
change but at least it made the code
look a little prettier
and then we got beautiful wonderful c
sharp six where we were able to declare
uh properties with just getters and we
had all the benefits of this
we had all the benefits of this but now
we didn't have to declare anything
immutable or have all this ugly
boilerplate
uh and it was just a beautiful thing
right
this was much better this was a huge
improvement
and now you know c-sharp eight well
introduced read-only structs which are
structs that uh can be declared
read-only it could declare it immutable
uh which again a really powerful concept
when you get into high-performance
computing so
as c sharp has evolved to embrace
functional concepts embraced high
performance uh really high performance
computing c-sharp has sort of changed
and added in these data structures
my preferred thing is to declare an
immutable class like this
or most of the work that i do which is
tends to be again in uh well a lot of
the work that i do not most of it but
i'd say it's about path.net framework
half.net core
so i use immutable classes everywhere
but c-sharp nine introduced record types
which again as we talked about earlier
are really powerful and you get
something that's a lot more succinct and
with structural equality out of the gate
which is a hugely powerful thing that uh
which is a hugely awesome concept
uh that uh you know prevents me from
having to write all the boilerplate to
make these all equitable or whatever
it's just you get that out of the box
which i love
it's like an anonymous type that you
declare so it's like a type
not to think about that one
let's talk about link link and uh
link and net in general
and let's talk specifically about
anonymous types link was a huge
innovation in.net uh was a huge uh
i wouldn't say it's an innovation per se
for programming but for net it was
awesome link was great and anonymous
types were right there alongside link as
one of the things that uh that we got
along with link
and this is what of course it looks like
we've all written code like this where
we have this anonymous type which again
is like a record type that is anonymous
you just can't you know you have no way
of declaring you're not declaring that
ahead of time so you just uh create
what's called you can do something like
this and create what's called a
projection right
and this is one of the best things about
anonymous types is they made them
immutable like that was the best
decision they could have possibly made
with anonymous types which i think
probably frustrated lots of dot-net
developers early on um but
as you dug into link as you started to
learn more about the language you
understood why that it did it
anonymous types again immutability and
structural equality built in much like
record types today we finally have
record types which is amazing uh except
in visual basic of course visual basic
loves to break the rules and so there is
no structural equality with an anonymous
type you actually have to declare
uh what your equality is using a key
parameter it's really weird
whatever
for the most part it doesn't bother me
because i don't have to write vb.net
that much but there it is
and this is a beautiful thing
you can't touch this this is nothing
there's nothing that you can edit about
this which is really good which is
really powerful
it means that you don't have to worry
about the state of these immutable
objects as they're being projected as
they're being shown on a page um
or as they're being manipulated in
memory they're just there
and then of course besides record types
we have this beautiful new c sharp
feature uh in the i believe the latest
version of c sharp might be nine i think
it's ten though um where we can now
declare
uh a new immutable type
uh from with that piggybacked from an
old one so you know if you declare me
and then you decide to click declare my
son and just copy over all the other
properties uh you can use the with
keyword to do that and the same thing is
uh available in record types as well uh
so worth bringing up if you hadn't seen
this before
hugely great new feature
so there are some let's let's talk about
some mutation anti-patterns
um
unnecessary setters being the first one
uh
i i when i
when i'm declaring using something like
entity framework i just expect that all
of the properties on there are going to
be mutable which makes good sense to me
right i think that um you know for for
what entity framework core is or entity
framework whatever you use um i think
that
um it makes a lot of sense for those
things to be mutable i mean after all
the underlying sql database uh is
mutable but when it comes to unnecessary
setters uh
this is one of those things where i i
think that
i i think that net developers in general
can start to think because i think
they're just used to hitting prop prop
tab and then just declaring the property
and moving on
here's a real world example that uh uh
that was real to me back when a few
years ago when i was working at a
company um and i was the um lead the
team lead for that particular
uh for that particular company and i had
this interface that just represented a
column i was doing some uh you know
reflective sql stuff under the hood with
something like this and the interface
was a lot bigger but for the purposes of
this this is basically what it looked
like it had a column name and a column
type
okay that makes good sense so i declared
an immutable object of column because to
me that made good sense at the time to
do so
and uh because at the end of the day
it's not like i'm going to change
the column mid-execution of the thing so
i would expect or if and if i i if i did
well i'd have to probably reevaluate my
architecture right i don't know why that
would be a good idea necessarily so had
this thing and i had it i had the
setters closed for a reason i didn't
want people to think that they should or
could change this interface um as it's
executing for any reason
so you know
i had a method called get columns for
table which would do some sql server
inspection you know uh inspection and uh
you know given a table i just wanted to
know all the columns of that table
without having to uh you know know the
type ahead of time
uh because we were using entity
framework but well it's a long story but
suffice it to say that uh this was one
of the things that we use in order to
interrogate like what tell hey table
tell me about yourself tell me what you
do so we get back something like this
so
you note that um for whatever reason in
the execution of our program we needed
this
id type that was a good or a unique
identifier in sql server we needed it to
be a string for whatever reason okay
and so i would get uh get these columns
for table and so there was some
refactoring that was done by a junior
developer who was like okay well if that
needs to be a string
that's super easy all i have to do is
add a setter to this property to this
interface
and then go ahead and fix all the
references to that to add setters to the
column implementation
and i'll just do one of these if column
you know four var column and columns if
the column type is type guide just
change it to type string
easy enough
to me though i looked at that and i
started to think like okay
again uh
what what is the what is the purpose of
this why is this particular or me i knew
that because i had known that because i
had written it
i had known you know why this is a bad
thing and so i use it as a cheating
moment but any other developer let's say
that i merge that pull request as is any
other developer who's coming to this
whose interface you know working with
this code now has to look at this i
column interface and think to themselves
why are all these 10 declared members
immutable except for this one
it's the easy way out it's just taking
mutability
uh take making something mutable just
for the ease of development so i use
this as a teaching moment
to say you know this isn't uh for that
junior developer
to talk about immutability to talk about
why taking and adding the setter was not
necessarily a good thing it was really
easy for them to do
but
there's lots of things that are taking
the easy way out in the job that we do
it doesn't mean that we should do them
and that's the that's ultimately the
message that i wanted to communicate to
that developer
so i encourage them to say instead of
using mutation use projection if you can
mutate your you can mutate your object
great but it's a lot better if you can
just project it to a new object
going back to uh
another kepler talk i love this slide
does just because you have a getter
doesn't mean you should have a matching
setter almost all of the time if i'm
declaring something that isn't an entity
uh that isn't a poco or a data dto data
transfer object uh or entity framework
core
i'm just closing those setters because i
don't need them i want to make my object
mutable by default for the most part
when it's practical and pragmatic
pragmatic
if i do this especially on something
like an interface i better have a good
reason for doing this on that interface
because at the end of the day i have to
look at that interface that i'm
declaring and say is that center open
because i'm expected to change it is it
because i'm allowed to change it what's
the impact of changing that again having
to now think deeply and really think
about the code and all of the execution
states that it's executing in
because at the end of the day if you
pass mutable data to methods you are
giving any method any user of that data
the permission to change that data when
it suits that method or that object or
whatever the case may be
right
you don't know you don't necessarily
know
how other people are going to use the
things that you provide them all of the
features that you provide them
so let's talk about setup methods this
is a particular anti-pattern that makes
me crazy
uh we were working very many years ago i
was working very many years ago uh
at a company where
we had a lot of offshore developers and
of course we know that we shouldn't do
when we make a
call inside of a constructor the
constructor should do really boring
stuff like either set data or throw
exceptions it shouldn't do anything like
call to a database although we all have
applications where that's the case right
there's the
we've all had applications early on in
the dot-net days where we had our
constructor do things that we shouldn't
have it do but getting beyond that for
the most part we know that constructors
are really good at creating objects let
them do that let them be that good
but this particular team this offshore
team loved to do uh something like this
where they would call init on that
service
and
then you could use that service right it
was doing something especially if it was
a um
a task-based initialization method right
where you were waiting on that init to
finish and then you could use the object
so what happens then if you did
something like this
well not by and large well i wouldn't
say by and large the people who knew
about the init they would call init but
junior developers uh or developers that
hadn't been exposed to this before would
just wrap that would just create the
repository they'd go along their merry
way
and then suddenly they'd call get data
and wondered why their code blew up well
this should work and then they'd get
cryptic exception cryptic exceptions
because of course you get a cryptic
exception uh
and then the whole thing blows up
and people are unhappy
a small example but
a real one where we we've all seen
something like this before we've all
experienced code like this before where
we didn't realize that we had to do
something else to that service ahead of
time
it's much better than to make that
service immutable
and use the factory pattern where we
create something that creates those
services for us uh especially if the
service creation has to come from
uh some kind of async await uh one of
the things that i see asked about freak
uh not frequently thank god not
frequently but uh so often is hey why
don't we have asynchronous constructors
which to me i just put my head in my
hands and i think oh my goodness
i i can't imagine why we would ever want
asynchronous constructors but getting
back to the main point favor the factory
pattern over using any kind of init or
service creation let the factory do the
hard work of creating the object for you
and then get your service make your
service immutable and you don't have to
worry about it you just get the data and
you just move on with your life teach
the factory how to make that service
before so you avoid that setup method
let's talk about some library support
for immutability
uh system collections immutable is
probably one of my favorite collections
if i can pass around immutable arrays uh
oftentimes i will try to pass in um you
know i'll try i will try to refactor my
code to pass around immutable arrays if
i can uh simply because
um
it's really obvious then to the
developer that uh you know you shouldn't
change this thing um although
oftentimes i'll just use a new i
innumerable as well
um depends on what it is depends on the
specific situation um so i i have a demo
but i don't really think uh
it's there's nothing really that special
about it but i will show it off anyways
um
that you can take and create an
immutable list here
like this using this you know fairly not
great syntax but you know is what it is
i usually just call as immutable array
or to immutable array i should say
create the immutable list
add something to that list which oh you
get a new you get a new immutable list
out of this
and then of course we write and realize
that as we write those lists to the
console that uh the accounts of these
lists are different because immutable
list allows you to mutate
that list but not really right it's
actually creating a new instance of a
list which is really useful
that's it you've never seen that before
sure most of us have experienced
something along those lines but
uh it's useful and the
system.collections.immutable has a ton
of things like this that uh allow you to
create and manipulate collections
in a way that guarantees that the copy
that you're working on cannot change
lists dot read only is another or sorry
list dot as read only is another example
of something that creates something that
is an immutable list
but it's not necessarily as flexible you
can't add things to it and get another
copy of an array of a list from it so
not as flexible but still available to
you as well
let's talk about automapper
automapper is one of my favorite.net
libraries for lots of reasons it keeps
me from writing really boring code um
really boarding boring glue code
so out of the box auto mapper supports
this thing where you can create
something where if you're trying to map
a person from an employee and that
person happens to be an immutable class
it will just work out of the box as long
as the property names are if as long as
the property names first name and last
name in this case they do
match
the uh
the object being created it will go
ahead and automatically wire that up and
pass those in for you
uh and now say for example you had
additional properties on this person
class is a mutable person class uh
that aren't available on the employee
class then you will not see those those
properties won't be or sorry that
constructor will blow up it won't work
in that case you can use something like
construct using which allows you to
specify hey if you have multiple
constructors or you have more data than
the employee class has or whatever the
case may be maybe the property names
differ you can just declare uh
that person object like that directly
using the construct using
while your map is uh being created
newtonsoft.json does the exact same
thing if you give it a person a
serialized object you get a person
object you want to serialize it it's an
immutable object and you give it some
json it will quote unquote just work
it's magic
at least that's you know in theory as
long as you're not missing properties in
which case you know you'll get
exceptions thrown or in the case of
having multiple constructors available
on that person object uh you would
create a you would mark it with a json
constructor attribute because it can
only use one of those attributes and it
does or sorry one can only use one of
those constructors it doesn't know which
one to use so you have to opt into that
specifically
and not just newtonsoft.json this is one
of those things that held over from
system.txt.json
uh lots of things changed between
newtonsoft and system.txt uh jason some
for the better some for the worse um
this is one that sort of that this makes
this one makes good sense to me
let's talk about the builder pattern
another great pattern for coupling a
mutable configuration object with an
immutable final state this is one of my
favorites and this is this is one of my
favorite patterns
um
that uh that i use uh frequently
especially when i'm creating library
methods for more complex projects
there's lots of there's i have customers
that
they they have a common library that's
shared amongst multiple things does that
sound familiar it should sound familiar
we probably have encountered that
problem yesterday today you know that's
a pretty common one so what i'll do is i
will use this builder pattern in order
to allow them to
create the configuration that they need
and then have its final state
question from anonymous real quick is
there any way to make ef core read into
immutable records the answer is yes and
it is a little bit further on i will get
to that good question
so uh db con so this is what the builder
pattern looks like so we have this db
context this is what an entity framework
does they have a db context options that
allows you that gives you a huge series
of properties in order to configure your
db context instance and you have
something where maybe get connection
string or use connection pool or
whatever the case may be
and then you have the you have the
builder and then you have the the db
context options this build method that
actually then creates the immutable copy
of those options
so this is what it looks like in
practice and i do this everywhere when
i'm creating library methods this is the
pattern that i use in order to ensure
immutability while this thing is
executing imagine if in the middle of
entity framework core you decided to
just change up and change the connection
string uh to a different database uh
there may be a reason that you would
want to allow that to happen but it's
not allowed out of the box for good
reason
so you build this options builder you
build your you use this immutable uh you
use this mutable object to configure
your db context instance and on the
other end of that uh is db context
options you get an immutable object with
no open setters so no junior developers
like well i need to change this
connection string to bump up the i have
no idea to bump up the connection the
max connection pool in the middle of
execution why i do you would ever do
that i wouldn't know but the point being
that
uh dbcontext entity framework core
doesn't want you to do this and you
shouldn't do this there's a reason why
they have this pattern and it's a really
powerful pattern especially if you're
providing library uh things library
methods or libraries to uh that uh that
button into asp.net core let them
configure it ahead of time and then use
it uh as they see fit but don't let them
change it
and this is where we get into the part
of the talk where we talk about the yin
and the yang i mentioned earlier i
talked about c sharp at the beginning
and said c sharp is my favorite language
did i say it was my favorite language it
is my favorite language let's just go
ahead and say it c sharp is my favorite
language it is my baby i built a company
around it uh i built a company around
the.net ecosystem and that has been
amazing um and i have yes i learned f
sharp um in a really terrible way by the
way that's kind of a funny story i um
decided to execute on this little side
project years and years ago and i
decided to use f sharp
uh as my language in order to learn f
sharp
that wasn't such a good idea a lot a lot
of a lot of long nights uh trying to
make that work because i didn't know
what i was doing but again getting back
to c sharp and what it embraces that
c-sharp is built on the clr the clr was
built with mutability by default most
things in c-sharp encourage you to be
mutable by default
and that's where we get into this idea
of this yin and yang this balancing act
that we have to do i cannot possibly
declare everything that i interact with
or everything that i have that i create
for people i cannot possibly declare it
as mutable
or immutable and feel good about that
thing because at the end of the day it's
kind of like putting lipstick on a pig
sure you can put lipstick on the pig
does it make the pig any more beautiful
let's talk about it any framework this
goes back to the question that was just
asked a few minutes ago can you make ef
core read into immutable records and the
answer is
yes
you can
and let's take a look at what that looks
like
entity framework really is a uh is a
language that really wants you to
declare really boring classes that have
getters and setters
which makes good sense and honestly
makes good sense as a foil or as a
complement to sql
because sql has mutable rows they have
the data within those rows can change
now of course you can create you can
make sql server be immutable you could
even you know talk about event sourcing
if you so those uh but at the end of the
day it's a good complement i want to
change this row so i'm going to set this
property called safe changes async and
you know be done with the whole thing
this is what it would look like
i'm sorry i laugh because this is this
is it
it looks so silly but this is what it
looked like at least at one point
vanity framework six to use entity
framework six with an immutable class
you'd have to declare a
constructor that is the quote-unquote
normal constructor that you would call
and
you would have to create another
constructor at the top and mark it as
obsolete and make sure that when they
used it by golly they better not use it
because you don't want them to use this
um this constructor so you declare it as
obsolete with the
yes
throw a compiler uh error if uh if
somebody tries to use this class so
already i can tell you that
i hate it i i hate looking at this this
absolutely looks ridiculous and note
that you have to declare uh fields and
there's a reason that you have to
declare fields it's because when you
call you're on model creating you know
skipping all the other stuff if you have
your database db set of points now you
have to go in and fill all the
properties and make them use private
fields instead
uh which it can do it absolutely an
entity framework core can do this for
you
but at the end of the day if you made
all of your ef core classes immutable uh
and
well first of all you'd have to think
about how you would start to go to
change them and then you have to think
about is it even worth doing to begin
with i was actually i found a blog post
which i uh really liked um
oh golly where'd it go um
excuse me for a second um there was a
blog post this person did on um
creating and i think there's you know if
you wanted to do something like this
i'll just say that the option to do so
is here for you uh this person and i
just googled it by talking about
immutable entities in ef core
but
it talks a lot it talks a little bit
about domain driven design it talks a
little bit about you know how to how you
would declare it um
and what boilerplate frankly is required
in order to make something like this
work uh i didn't read through this blog
post uh entirely but apparently get
atomic values is a thing where they you
know you get an enumerable list of all
of the values of this particular set for
probably what's a good reason and i
assume that
this is this is looks like to be
um basically how you would mutate that
object to begin with which is you'd
close all the setters you declare the
stuff that you'd want to declare as
private uh as private and then you'd go
down here and you would see okay well
this is how i would add an item to this
order this is how i would delete an item
for this order
and you know i think that if you really
wanted to make entity framework core
uh work with immutability you probably
could do that yet at the end of the day
you have to ask yourself why because at
some point you're not making your job or
anybody else's job any easier you're
just sort of
making sort of fitting a square peg into
a round hole right it's uh
it does it just you can just because you
can do something doesn't mean that you
should and
again entity framework core is a great
example of something that really
embraces mutability by default making it
immutable technically possible but is it
worth doing and i would argue that it's
not and that goes back to the balancing
act question how do you balance
immutability
with mutability uh inside of a language
that really wants you to be mutable uh
and the ways that i do that are using
the builder pattern using factory
patterns to make sure that my services
using the factory pattern to make sure
that my services that i'm creating don't
mutate themselves as part unless they
really need to as part of what they do
uh
try to think what else if i have if
those services themselves typically if
they're calling an api i will have them
return uh immutable objects if i can um
especially now that record types are a
thing inside of c sharp um that be that
makes that a lot easier
um
because at the end of the day we're
developers and we have to be conscious
of the fact that we're spending lots of
money that we're that our our work that
we do is expensive
and
just because we can make something
immutable
yes that is but is it worth the extra
yes it is possible but is it worth the
extra time and money to do so oh and of
course i'm in norway so we need to use
this right
time is money and some things are just
not worth taking the time to do and i
would argue that
um mutability in many ways is a lot
easier to accomplish and a lot easier to
get your job done than it is using
immutability in something like c sharp
so my takeaways are is that because
i live in a world of mutability by
default i have to program defensively i
cannot assume that if i see an open
setter or i see an object that is a poco
i have to assume that at some point
somebody will want to change something
about that object even if i don't want
them to and this is where the manual
boring stuff comes in i wouldn't say
it's boring but code reviews this is
where code reviews come in to really
read each other's code to figure out
what it is that this code is doing why
it is that you needed to change this
particular thing or open this setter on
this thing that was on the center that
was previously closed
but programming defensively is really
sort of a requirement right
it's not like f sharp where
well i i'd say f sharp is kind of a bad
example f sharp lives in a clr world so
lots of use of f sharp uses
frameworks and libraries that are
written in c sharp so naturally there's
lots of mutability there's lots of times
that if you're using f sharp you're
mutating objects anyways right but if
you're using a purely functional
programming language you can assume
safely for most in most cases that
the state of that object isn't going to
change whereas in c sharp we just don't
have that i mean a lot of this talk the
point of this talk is to say that
immutability is great and immutability
is powerful but it's like functional
programming in anything else sprinkling
it in pragmatically or sprinkling it in
where it makes sense
is
ultimately the the message that this
talk intends to send
mutating sparingly um this is something
that i mean unless i'm doing something
like um using entity framework core and
mutate that all the time because i'm
just most of the time a lot of what we
do is just changing records inside of a
database so mutating sparingly becomes a
it becomes is this even possible
uh the thing that i would say is that
for certain libraries it makes a lot of
sense for other libraries it makes it
for other libraries it makes no sense at
all to not make something mutable to
make it immutable it doesn't make sense
so
but there are things that you can do you
know if you declare services um make
them so that their their their
dependencies are immutable and i think
the most of the c-sharp
and net core examples uh asp.net core
specifically when you you know if you
talk about a dependency injection most
of the services that you that you
declare are probably immutable with all
of their dependencies are immutable
they're using private read-only
properties on the back end keep doing
those things and if you have services
with open setters
you have to you have to start to wonder
why those setters are open to begin with
it's much easier to reason about a
service if you just close those setters
off
um yeah and then of course there's team
alignment
you at the end of the day when you're
making a decision to try to make parts
of your application parts of your
c-sharp more functional or try to
introduce mutability or immutability as
it were inside of your project you have
to have alignment with your team to
understand the common goals what are we
trying to accomplish uh if you're making
this boring service that gets data from
something and you just want to make it
immutable because you're only it's a
read-only service it's a weather service
and you know the weather's the weather
is going to change but you're not going
to try to change the data that you get
from that weather service to you know
tweak it to make it warmer or colder or
change the weather
you're just going to take that you're
just going to take that data and uh do
something with it so it makes total
sense to make the return call from that
service to uh make it immutable because
it would make no sense for you to change
it
things like that are pretty commonplace
and i don't think that you would um you
would get much pushback but if you
suddenly came in and tried to make uh
entity framework core every object
immutable uh especially if you're
talking about a fairly large established
project you're probably gonna get some
pushback
if you shoehorn immutability
immutability into net and sacrifice
readability or maintainability along the
way you've really not improved your
solution you've transferred the problem
or made the problem worse you've made
the code less readable you've made uh
the code more complicated to reason
about we go back to reasoning it was it
is a lovely thing to look at an object
know that it's not going to change
and no knowing that it's not going to
change be able to reason really well
going back to that twitter example i
know that if i retweet something i never
have to worry about that tweet being
edited to change the thought to maybe
something that i don't believe right
that's a perfect that's a lovely thing
to be in but at the end of the day i'll
go back to csarpen.net and the clr in
general
not really embracing that very well the
libraries that are created do not really
embrace immutability super super well so
you can sprinkle it in just like link
and functional programming you can
sprinkle it in where it makes sense but
at the end of the day there's lots of
places where it simply just doesn't make
sense to do
and immutable thinking is really the the
immutable thinking is really the most
the the most powerful takeaway it wasn't
necessarily creating
you know creating now learning f-sharp
and then now declaring all of my all of
my types as immutable it had me more
thinking what i took away from
functional programming was thinking more
about the state of my program and it was
a mind-blowing thing when i kind of
realized all the potential that um
that
pragmatic functional programming and
immutability could add to my application
persistent data structures are a
beautiful thing a mutable list being an
example something that you know is not
going to change
but it's not always available everywhere
redux is another uh is an example that's
outside of the c-sharp ecosystem if
you're a react developer um you may have
you might you probably have used redux
in some form one of the things one of
its principles is that state doesn't get
mutated it gets
updated but the state itself doesn't get
mutated directly which enables so many
great things like time travel debugging
if you're seeing how the state of your
application application changed uh over
time um or the state of your react
application changes over time and you're
able to go back to a certain specific
piece of state while you're debugging
your application that gives you a lot of
power
um undo redo becomes undo redo becomes
really easy uh when you build redux or
when you when you have this idea that
state gets preserved between state
updates you just create a new copy of
state and you update that instead as
opposed to erasing the old state or
overriding parts of that old state which
is a really powerful concept i used this
to create a really slick interface a
long time ago for a project that
unfortunately was ultimately abandoned
and one of the things i took was like
okay well i have to use angularjs for it
uh but i learned from redux and i
decided to preserve my state um as i
changed it as opposed to
um
as opposed to uh you know trying to
mutate it in place and what it enabled
was a really easy to create undo redo
because all i'd have to do is take that
previous state overwrite the old state
and boom i had undo and redo as it were
and again at the end of the day um
maybe if i'm able to change your mind
that would be great i would be i would
if depending on the uh opinions that you
had about immutability
um
you know maybe i was able to change your
mind a little bit about so or get you
thinking about certain things because at
the end of the day even if we can't
change the data in our data structures
maybe
maybe we can change the world
and uh that is the end i appreciate you
all being here uh i wish again that i
could be there in person to uh to to see
all of you beautiful norway i heard it
snowed uh which they had the first snow
of the late part of the year which is
amazing i wish i could have been there
to see it so uh you've been a great
audience and uh i we have a few minutes
left so if you're interested in staying
for questions i don't see any questions
um or if you have any questions you can
always slack me after the talk or email
me find me on twitter
but otherwise i appreciate you've been a
great audience thank you very much
i'm hearing your applause in my head
because i the sound isn't coming through
oh there it is i love it thank you very
much
you